hello everyone
I hope everyone's doing fine today got a
lot of material to cover today so I'm
gonna be moving right along the other
day I had a debate with an individual
who claims to be a physicist his name is
Peter and it was on this program
it's jf geez calm jfg because it's very
hard to pronounce his last name I guess
Caribe gory epi and known as the public
space it's a podcast
he brought physicist Peter and who
debated me on not only physics but in
general but also on the Rope model okay
so I'm gonna be analyzing what we
discussed it took three hours that's how
long it lasted so there were it was a
long debate and a lot of it probably was
unnecessary we just went into so many
details that you know I think a lot of
people were turned off but you know at
the same time that's what science is
sometimes you have to get to the
nitty-gritty and that takes time and
that takes space so keep that in mind
anyways we had a debate and these are
the problems that I saw with a debate
I'll call it the Peter problems and I'll
call Peter problem because he has to
remain anonymous and I'm saying that
that's a problem I'm gonna talk about
that in a second here he didn't
understand the golden principle of
physics and he said he did that he
agreed with it but then he never used it
and whenever I confronted him he
rejected it I'm gonna talk a little bit
about that quite a bit in fact about
that
and I'll probably won't be able to cover
all these subjects today so I'm gonna
leave those two next week if necessary
but this is the material I'm going to be
covering he invokes mathematical physics
jargon and therefore you know a lot of
unscientific notions so we need to know
what science is we need to put this in
the context of science and physics he
dismissed strategic words as petty
semantics these are words that made our
brain made or broke his arguments and he
was not aware of that and so I'm gonna
show where he fails on this this is an
important point a lot of people just
want to say uh bill but you're just
doing semantics well it's more than
semantics what we have here is a
situation where words matter and he
didn't read up on a rope hypothesis that
was quite unfortunate
he also you invoked the planetary model
of the atom to make his case it's Bohr's
model the Bohr rather bored model you
know the orbiting bead and mechanic
quantum mechanics they do you know they
do that quite a bit they always use the
planetary model for almost every
explanation and and then what happens is
they dismiss it they denied at the end
of the show they say you know oh by the
way you know that atom I was talking to
you for the last hour
that's not our atom and they do the same
thing to high school years they said you
know you go to high school they teach
you the planetary model and you say what
is that really the the super duper you
know I'll then take atom and they'll say
well no when you get to college you know
we'll show you the real one and so
that's that's somewhat of a problem
and because of that you know since you
have the orbiting bead he had to
improvise a bogus fabric medium he
called it the rag or you know the
potential or whether you use all these
names to refer to it and again it shows
that he didn't understand the golden
principle of physics as I said in point
number two there and so I dismiss him as
a physicist he's not a physicist is an
abstract
he does so-called physics with
abstractions if you got to abstractions
you're an abstruse it's not up physicist
physics is the opposite of abstract
anyways these are the problems I'm gonna
be dealing with let's start with the
first one anonymity Peter decided to
remain anonymous he did not furnish his
last name live he claimed he asked to be
presented as an experimental and venal
Fein phenom analogical physicist okay
and again I'm saying that's an absence
it's not a physicist because what he
does what phenomenology does is the
application of theoretical physics to
experimental data by making quantitative
predictions so if he's got to be doing
predictions and he's gonna be doing
quantitative he's he's an abstruse he's
not a physicist and predictions already
take them outside of science let alone
out of physics we don't do predictions
in science you know maybe he's not an
abscess maybe he should be regarded as
an astrologer or or a palm reader those
people do predictions and you might say
well bill what are you saying here are
you saying that you know that in physics
and in science you don't do predictions
you know these this notion that science
is associated with prediction or the
predictions are associated with science
that's been around for decades now Karl
Popper talked about them you know
30s and 40s so you know it's like it's
it's common knowledge that predictions
are part of science and people get you
know horrified when I told you no
predictions have nothing to do with
science so let's let's put predictions
in the right context so that we
understand what the mathematicians mean
by predictions and why it's not a part
of science not the word prediction at
least here's a prediction for you here's
a paper that these guys have and this
paper says predictions from an
anisotropic inflationary era what are
they talking about inflation is guts
having guts
I guess I don't know how you pronounce
his name exactly you know inflation is
what happened after the first few
microseconds or seconds after the Big
Bang 14 billion years ago there was a
rapid process okay and they call that
rapid process inflationary theory
anyways now it's part of standard
cosmology all these astronomers they
believe in this inflation theory and
here these people talk about making
predictions of an inflationary phase you
say hold it
what do you mean prediction you're
predicting the what happened fourteen
billion years ago you know what do you
mean by this what do you mean you're
predicting are you predicting the past
is that what you're doing and and so
there's something something seems in
Congress here they're talking about what
happened fourteen billion years ago and
they're using the word prediction and
you're saying what can that possibly
mean in that context what could the word
prediction meaning in the context of
fourteen billion years ago usually we
predict the future not the past
imagine you go to the astrologer yeah
and
and he said I'm gonna make a prediction
I said okay make a prediction he says
I'm gonna predict when you were born huh
what do you mean and from some kind of
trade you found out my my birthday he
says I predict you were born on the
Norman November 19 1952 well you said
it's correct but is that a prediction so
something is wrong here something is in
Congress how can you predict what
happened 14 billion years ago and this
is the context the context is these
people are not predicting what they're
doing is explaining but they never
realize that you know they're explaining
they call that a prediction they're
making a model they're making a model of
what the initial conditions could have
been or should have been 14 billion
years ago in order to arrive at where we
are today it's kind of like this like
let me give you an example
fourteen billion years ago you say there
were caterpillars that's why we have
butterflies today it's more or less like
that so if we verify that we have
butterflies today we say ah that
confirms my theory that the initial
conditions were you know caterpillars
it's more or less like that but what
they're doing is explaining why there
are butterflies today it's not a
prediction you know it's like it's like
when I I do predictions all the time my
famous prediction is the extinction you
know mass extinctions what do I say how
do i phrase it I say well imagine you
we're at the starting line of the
Cambrian 542 million years ago okay so
now if you're standing there you can
predict quotations here okay you can
predict and I'm trying to explain
extinction right fast extinction but I'm
saying what if you were standing at the
Cambrian line you can predict that
certain plants are going to periodically
disappear so the ferns disappeared they
were replaced by conifers conifers
disappeared
were replaced by angiosperms flowering
plants and when the that transition
happened at some point there that's when
all the animals became extinct of that
era why because all these animals these
dynasties of animals forge a
relationship with those plants for
millions of years they can't change
their diet at the last moment and so
where the plants disappeared they
disappeared and the new plants came out
so is that a prediction no I'm trying to
explain extinction I'm trying to explain
extinction based on the fact that you
know plants have been replaced
periodically over time so they call that
a prediction it's not a prediction I'm
trying to explain a mechanism how Mother
Nature does mass extinctions well it's
similar to this what they do is they go
back in time they say if these were the
initial conditions right after the Big
Bang we should expect this to be
observed today it's not a prediction
they're trying to explain why we ended
up the way we ended up that's what
they're doing they call these
explanations they call them predictions
they're simply running a thought
experiment in which a movie they want
you to watch and they say the reason we
have galaxies and stars and gases and
matter and that's the way we have today
it's because this should have happened
sometime in the past that's what they're
doing it's not a prediction so no we
don't do predictions any more than you
know weather yeah and it's interesting I
looked up deductive and inductive
predictions and they don't use
essentially the word prediction what
they say they use the word explanation
you can look it up yourself you'll see
that the so called prediction is really
an explanation they're trying to explain
something and so they go through this
inductive and deductive reasoning
deductive being you know when you can
guarantee the result that's math and
then they have the inductive one where
it's usually qualitative explanations
and they're trying to explain something
they're trying to explain some result
and they say if a and
then see that's not a prediction yeah
it's not a prediction what that is is an
explanation in one case a description in
another that's all it is so now there
are no prediction we don't do
predictions in science unless you can
justify what a prediction is prediction
is is what astrologers do and then you
want to dismiss that as oh no those are
prophecies well yeah there is no
different
prophecy in a prediction the only
predictions there that you can say
relate to science and they're not
they're really not is like when you do
an experiment you can tell me the exact
result of an experiment then you could
talk about doing predictions and since
nobody can do that there there are no
predictions although you all we have is
intelligent guesses you know and I
always give that example of the guy who
lets go his pen a hundred times is I can
predict the pen is gonna fall to the
floor unambiguously that's it okay so he
does it a hundred times and I say okay
I'll bet you a beater that knot won't
fall to the floor because usually it
happens on a 100 first time that you do
it he said you're crazy well that's
right okay so he lets go of the pen and
this time it doesn't fall to the floor
it stays in the air how does that happen
see you didn't predict the brilliance
stayed in here turns out I have a couple
magnets that are holding the thing up in
the air so he's counting on gravity he
wasn't aware that I had these two
magnets so he didn't predict he was
guessing he had an intelligent guess
that based on his experience it was
gonna fall to the floor but he wasn't
aware that I had two magnets I cheated
yes but I won the beer okay there is no
such thing as prediction in science we
do not predict what we do is explain so
yeah so when so if Peter what he does
his due predictions then he's already on
the wrong foot and by the way I do want
to commend
him on the other hand side negative I
gotta say about him I think he's uh he's
a pretty intelligent guy you know
unfortunately is using his intelligence
to do quantum mechanics and the only
thing I can recommend to him is that you
know he get out of the particle model
because he's not gonna answer any
questions with particles but on the
other hand he is I think a serious
researcher and that is commendable I
have a lot of respect for that okay so I
want us to put that on the line as well
anyways what are the problems with with
what he what Peter was saying well the
first one was you know that he didn't
give his name and I think that has a lot
to do with the environment that we have
today in science that people are scared
to really go out on the limb and that's
unfortunate
in his case he's a young guys trying to
make his way in you know his career etc
and if he has different ideas or you
know he wants to explore different
alternatives he should not be censored
because of this and the only reason I
can think of that he wanted to remain
anonymous is the environment that we
haven't seen in so-called science today
and that is that we have which ones and
people are worried about losing their
jobs or their careers because they went
out there and they said something and
their colleagues look at him to say well
what did you say what did you say about
quantum what did you say about general
relativity and so they're scared and so
they'd rather not you know give their
names out or be too popular when when
they're raising issues that can be
considered or regarded as being crank or
crackpot theories or whatever so that's
I think the worry otherwise I don't know
why he would want to remain anonymous
and I'm gonna honor that by the way I'm
gonna come out of the closet on his own
I'm using this scientific context okay
okay
the first issue I had let me put that up
there one more time where is it the
problems unanimity a second one he
didn't understand the golden principle
of physics let's look at that one here's
the golden principle I said he hinted
him that you know the golden principle
physics is that physics requires an
object you can't do physics without an
object and Peter says probably you're
right and then in shortly after that he
said you do new you do need an object
well he said all this but he didn't he
doesn't understand the contract that he
signed here you know how can you say
that you need an object and then the
rest of your presentation you do
concepts and again every year word in
the dictionary can be divided into two
categories objects and concept there is
no other no third category if you do you
have to tell me what it what it's in
what way it's different than the concept
for an object so what is an object it's
that which has shape that's what it is
and a concept is a word that invokes
embodies two objects you need to define
the word object before you define a word
concept object is to one what concept is
to - okay that's that's the beginning
that's the starting point okay and but
we never got to a real definition of
object both I'll get to that in a second
so so where's the problem the problem is
that Peter sends me four papers this was
ahead of the debate again seventy four
papers and I read those papers and it
turns out that the you know they contain
no objects whatsoever
they're all concepts and for a guy who
says that he agrees that there has to be
an object that's kind of weird and we
got a problem we got to resolve that
there's a problem there okay so here are
the four papers that
sends me he sends me the following
papers and I look at him not one of them
contains a picture of drawing of an
object they're all concepts and jfg last
time not this time around but the the
previous time when he interviewed me
online he came up with the idea that
well you know concepts always implicitly
have an object underlying them that was
what he was saying yeah but in physics
you have to identify that object you
can't just talk about fields energy
force mass whatever and and not talk
about the elephant that's underneath all
that or the or whatever object that
you're gonna use so the object must be
identified and we don't have that in all
of mathematical physics in other words
if you look at all the invisible
mediators like for life or gravity for
magnetism etc we don't have the
mathematical physics does not provide
the invisible mediators okay and and
that's that's the problem today the
problem is that we don't have physical
mediators and okay let's look at that
first paper the first paper is Tana
Maura's paper okay so experimental
confirmation of the aharonov-bohm effect
okay we'll say what are they talk about
well in this paper they talk about the
existence of an effect that first line
already is unscientific why because
effect is a concept it's not a physical
object and I'm not and this is not
semantics fellows okay this is that you
can only talk about the existence of
objects in physics and in science it is
an ordinary speech where we can talk
about the existence of concepts for the
purposes of physics you can't say that
love exists you can't say that
intelligence exists you can't say
information exists and of course you
cannot say that an effect exists and
this is so that first line already makes
it on scientific it would
been rejected never been published in a
scientific magazine but in mathematics
everything is possibly published this
stuff and further down below you'll see
again demonstrated the existence of the
a B effect again existence of an effect
so they're kind of trying to prove they
talk about demonstrating meaning they're
they're proving okay the existence of an
effect and so so we got a stop there we
got it we got to analyze what what this
is all about because this is not
semantics this is getting to the heart
of what the problem is the word exists
belongs exclusively to physics it
doesn't belong to religion anyone using
the word exists has crossed the line
into physics why because physics is the
science of existence physics only
studies that which exists we have to
define the word exist and it's never
been defined I'm the first person who
defines it I'm not cleaning I'm not
boasting here I'm just saying a fact the
fact is that no one has ever defined a
word exists in fact if you go to
Stanford encyclopedia of philosophy
they go the pho who you know defines the
word exists goes through this whole
analysis to our analysis in Indiana he
said well you know we still haven't
reached a decision so he doesn't know
what exists means you look it up in the
Wikipedia again you don't have any idea
what exists means there's all these if
ands and buts and funny thing is that
when you go to the Catholic Encyclopedia
you you will not even find the
definition of the word exist there's no
analysis whatsoever nothing written
about it and yeah exist for the purposes
of science means physical presence
physical involves an object you must
have an object to talk about exists
concepts cannot exist not in science in
ordinary speech yes none science if it
once if God once exists he's got to also
have location not only does he have to
be an object a human being a flaming
bush whatever he's got to have location
God cannot be great
and pretend to exist you do not pray to
grace you pray to a man a bearded guy
out there who's gonna concede you know a
favor to you but you cannot pray to a
concept you cannot pray to love okay
love doesn't have ears to hear you so so
for existence to work for that word to
be used consistently scientifically
rationally you must have a physical
object and that's not enough it has to
have location there's got to be a
distance between God's chest and my
chest or between God's you know body and
a chair and a tree okay so exist is
important because the word exist is
important just like the word object is
important in physics because physics is
the science of existence physics only
studies objects that exist physics on
each study is that which exists and
anything that does not exist physics not
interested okay so continuing with Tana
Mora here and real quick you can see
down there at the bottom it says even
when the magnetic field was confined a
field confined how do you confine a
field in the field is a concept and
again these are not semantic arguments
these are things you know these are
words that these people use as physical
objects they're treating field which is
a concept they're treating it as a
physical object so we do have to get to
the bottom of what a field is before we
can talk about its existence or or
confining it doing anything with it can
you do anything with a field and for
that we go to the word field let me get
it up here and this is these are fields
what is a field well in the religion of
mathematics a field is a quantity this
is out of Wikipedia okay but you can
look it up anywhere else you'll find
more or less the same notion that has a
value for each point in space and time
field is essentially quantities in a
region that's what a field means region
region of values that's
it is and there you have a few regions
of values the first line up there with
objects the bottom the one below the
line are without objects and so if we're
gonna like math math or like
mathematical physics does all the time
they dispense with objects then at the
bottom you have it without the objects
you have fields that have no objects in
them that's the what is it the raw field
you could say that's what I feel this
and what are we staring at
well we're staring at vectors each one
of those arrows are not Indian arrows
they are vectors what is a vector it's
it's a aligned mathematical concept that
has only magnitude and direction so it's
a value it's a it's a quantity that's
all it is
that's what those arrows are so what is
a field it's a bunch of vectors a bunch
of quantities and directions that's it
and what is a what is a particle that
you say well it's a field it's a
vibrating field they're saying that
these vectors these lines are vibrating
and what are the lines they were
magnitudes they're numbers so the number
five is vibrating that's essentially
what they're telling you this is not
semantics folks this goes to the heart
of what these people are saying they're
saying that a particle is a vibration of
a field and so what is a field a field
is a bunch of numbers and they're saying
the numbers are vibrating and that's
what creates a particle that's what
these people are saying so yes it's
important to analyze the word field and
no this is not semantics this has to do
with the foundations what this guy has
in his theory he's saying a particle
he's presenting a particle you say it's
it's a vibration of a field first
vibrations a verb so if a particle is a
vibration he's automatically turned them
down into a verb or you turned a verb
into a noun that's the first one the
second one is the vibration of word of a
concept of a number of a value of a
quantity so this is the issue the issue
there is no physical object called
yield and these people are treating the
word field as an object this is the
problem you have quantum field theory
and so on today that's replaced of
particle so Tana Mora already has a
bunch of problems with this paper and
this is this is just the abstract by the
way so we have a problem with existence
of effects of concepts we have problem
with the field but then we have a bigger
problem here also it says measure
between two electron waves passing
through spaces inside and outside a tiny
ferromagnet electron waves
what are they say here how can a we have
electron waves when the same Tana Mora
wrote a paper which I analyzed in my
video the one about the slit experiment
you can look up in my site you'll find a
slit experiment in there I talked about
Tana Maura's paper and here it is this
is his paper the one at the bottom we
have mr. Murli an Italian group that
handled one electron at a time or so
they claimed Tana Mora handled single
electron buildup of an interference
pattern so he says he handled single
electrons so he's treating the electron
here in this paper he dealt with it
as a particle now in his new paper each
treats it as what treats it as a wave he
said electron waves passing through
spaces so we got her a little bit of a
problem here because you know these
people use the wave when it's to their
advantage and then they treat it as a
particle in in another context you see
what's happening here you know we have
here the electron waves and here in this
one he talks about single electron
single electrons in other words treating
it as a particle it is this thing the
fact that the sometimes talk about
particles and sometimes about ways that
allows them to cover all the bases wave
is a concept particle if we're talking
about a corpuscle because that's
essentially what he's referring
when he's a single electron he's saying
a ball hit the wall right you know
that's an object so so the electron is
both a concept and an object and that's
what allows them to get around you know
any criticism of their physical
interpretations the fact that they're
treating God is both concept as an
object god is this human like magician
that made the universe right and God is
also maybe a flaming bush that's on one
hand that's the object and then as a
concept you know you gather the New
Testament you listen to John and he says
you know by the way you know God is love
God is spirit so what is God is God an
object or he's got a concept and we have
the same problem with the electron the
electron
according to Tana Morra passes through
this slit you know through the space in
the slit passes as a wave and then he
detects it at the screen as a whole as a
particle as a you know the cannonball
hit hit the wall made a hole and so you
know what is the electron and for this
we don't have to talk about his
conclusions but we have to do is say
look Tana Morra begin by drawing your
atom let's let's look at your atom let's
see what you're talking about before we
can get into your theory and that's the
problem we had also with Peter he didn't
understand that he thought that was neat
peeking or doing semantics no no we need
to know what your atom looks like before
you start your theory other words we're
not gonna listen to your theory it's
worthless you could be talking about
spirits and angels for all we care
you need to draw the atom you need to
tell us what your atom looks like and
specifically you know if we have the
electron bead going around the atom if
that's gonna be your your the bead
that's gonna hit the wall the electron
bead that's gonna hit the wall because
you pulled it out of the atom is that's
gonna be your theory then we need to
know you know why that
electron beet sticks to the atom to
begin with why does it fly away
normally why do we need to heat up for
example the the atom to ionize it why
isn't it ionizing on taneous yet you
know at every moment why doesn't the
atom disintegrate and that's when he
came up with the rag but you can see the
problems with Tamura Tamura first talks
about exists existence of concepts let
me put that up there again he talks
about existence of effects he talks
about fields confining fields and he
talks about electron waves when what
he's detecting are particles so you know
his whole report here is worthless it
has nothing to do with science ok so
it's important to trash whatever his
group did because all they're doing is
it's just doing a bunch of verbiage and
it doesn't conduce to anything we are
not understanding what these guys are
doing they think they detected single
electron hits on the wall and you know
when you know there is no evidence of
that their language completely is is
bogus anyways none of it passes the
minim criteria of science so Tana
Maura's reports are worthless has no
place in science that's Tana Mora what
was the next paper the next paper was a
superposition paper for the three slit
experiment now we don't have two slits
or once they know we have three slits
okay and here it is this is what it
looks like here's the paper okay exotic
looped trajectories of photons and 3/6
interference well again we're gonna have
the same similar problem because they're
talking about trajectories of photons
they're assuming a photon is a discrete
particle they treat it as such whenever
it's convenient to them and when it's
not convenient to them they bring in the
wave and they say well it's an L long
gated way
you've made of many links many
wavelengths okay okay the first problem
I found is that you know they say
tenants they say the validity of the
superposition principle and a Bors rule
are well accepted tenants of quantum
well the word is tenants and that
already gave me an idea that now do we
need the the authors of this report but
the peer reviewers we're not paying too
much attention because that caught my
attention immediately and so that's the
first just a minor thing there but just
keep that in mind for when you see these
papers that are set to be peer reviewed
by the highest peer reviewers on earth
well not so you know everybody missed
that you know and that's the first line
and it wasn't correct if that means you
wonder about both the authors and the
peer reviewers so where's the problem
well again they talk about predictions
and here they talking about well
accepted tenets of quantum mechanics
well accept it by home was it by
mathematicians you know I mean well
accepted is like saying you know we
proved it so you better swallow it okay
because we already proved it it's well
accepted okay so what do they talk about
here they talk about superposition
principle what the hell is a
superposition principle
well I dealt with that a couple weeks
ago more like a month like this let's
look at let's let's rehash our
superposition nonsense here first of all
here we have this is the other side of
that report the first one was the
official report this is what they
published in quantum optics and again
they say it's and and this is the
context they're saying first they put a
prize okay for it he who could disprove
the principle of superposition and with
it they would disprove quantum mechanics
and so first they offer a prize and
second which is very unscientific you
know science is not a
a beauty contest where you get medals
and prizes okay
and second they talk about disproving
okay again has nothing to do a sign this
proof means that you do not believe
that's what it means
you know they've already proven God
some people they disproved it to other
people so who's right well it depends on
your personal beliefs so this proving
and proving have nothing to do with
physics and again they're to investigate
whether superposition really occurs in
nature so they're talking about just
verifying whether something occurs in
nature and whether something occurs in
nature and that's not science science is
about explaining why or the cause of
something not to except to say that it
does occur you know if I throw a stone
through the window and break it and they
say well once you repeat my experiment
to see if it's true and so now I throw a
stone through windows hey yeah it's true
you know every time I throw a stone
through a window breaks it is that
science or a science understanding how
the window broke explaining how the
window broke but to repeat an experiment
like you know throwing the pen letting
go the pen letting it fall to the floor
constantly say well yeah pen always
falls to the floor is that science is
that physics that that's the point the
point is that we need to understand what
causes the pen to fall to floor not to
run an experiment a million times as
here yeah the pen always falls to the
floor I did the experiment repeatedly so
I'm doing science because of that okay
so superposition what did we cover a
couple weeks ago or a month ago or
whatever
here's superposition and decoherence you
got both of them here pretty much
superposition means you can have two
states of a particle at the same
location and then the other one is that
you
and have the particle with two places at
once
that's the coherence okay so we have the
superposition decoherence right there
you know and this is not mine by the way
this is from the official people of you
know this is the party line didn't
understand well maybe you can get a
better glimpse here where we have what's
his name dr. quantum and he does the
coherence with particles as always you
know so let's start at the beginning
let's wait here for a second until it
starts at the beginning you'll see in a
minute how dr. quantum cries I like that
I put that in there you know you'll see
you're in a second he's crying because
he can't figure out how this universe
works that's why he's crying okay
anyways he starts out with a marble
machine so he's got to do it with
particles and what particle is he gets
once then he gets just one mine puts two
slits you're supposed to get two lines
but he always does it with particles and
now he gets you know the fringes okay
that's the slit experiment then he tries
one bullet at a time and since he can't
explain why it also produces fringes
what he does that's the explanation he
does he says well what we have is that
the particle is at two places at once
and then and when it goes to the to the
blackboard there or the screen whatever
is behind that then he says well the
particle is now you know are both at the
same place at the same time so what
they're doing is cheating they're saying
you know since we cannot explain this
rationally what we do is we say that the
particle is at two places at once
when it hits the two slits there's only
one particle but it's of two places at
once and then when it goes to the screen
or to the blackboard there what happens
is the the the the single particle comes
back together and
and forms a whole a single whole you
know on the blackboard and ya know
that's why he cries because that's the
best he can do to explain you know the
slit experiment and this is cheating
this is cheating first because you know
first they play around between particles
and waves you know and I always liked an
analogy for that you know
did you see the Leprechaun yeah I saw
and I tried to grab him to steal his
gold and what happened well he turned
into a spirit so I couldn't grab him you
know I mean anyone can explain physics
like that if you could convert the
particle into a wave and wave into a
particle at your convenience that's had
hot and that's not very scientific a
little more scientific is maybe Karl
poppers suggestion even though I don't
agree with it but that's beside the
point because the mathematicians agree
with Karl Popper and Karl Popper says
look if an experiment falsifies your
theory you have to reject a theory all
experiments 150 percent of all
experiments ever done debunk falsify
quantum mechanics they falsify that
light cannot or the electron cannot be a
particle a discrete particle not not one
experiment that one experiment can
explain can be explained with a particle
model not one look what I'm saying and
so hold it how about the quantum of the
continent fact for example that I'm
gonna be dealing with that in a second
Compton effect is a particle you know
shows the particle nature of light no it
does because if you read quantum
Compton's paper it talks about
wavelength so what wavelength does a
particle have and that's when they have
to go to this duality where you know you
have the little wave but it's a wave
packet it's kind of chalk
Dolf at the edges and which comes to to
the question you know where there's a
weight begin where does a wave end I
mean it's easy to say that but what are
we talking about what is this wave wave
or what and they never go through all
that stuff they say oh that's semantics
that's philosophy that's metaphysics so
they dismiss all that say let's do the
math the issue is that you know you
cannot explain even Compton the Compton
effect or the photoelectric effect for
that matter because they all involve
wavelengths slit experiment wavelength I
mean that's how Thomas Young did it in
1800 he became famous because he
presented the slit experiment in terms
of wave length and all of these are done
in terms of waves and wave lengths and
particle is incompatible with waving
with wave length so that's not when they
use the quantum I mean if you look at
the standard model there's no such thing
as a wave all you see is these particles
not one of which has a picture in them
that means that they don't know what
they look like they've never observed a
particle as they always claim oh we
observe now they didn't observe anything
they're blind you can't see an invisible
entity by definition of the word
invincible so you can't see a photon you
can't see an electron if you know if
that's what they think they accelerated
you got the Swedish group that says they
filmed an electron what are they filmed
they don't even know what they fell
anyways the point here is the following
is the phone that you need an object you
need a physical object before you can do
physics you have to identify the
invisible object the one that's doing
the phenomena the thing that you're
looking at and they can can't do that
that's why we don't have a picture of a
single particle in the standard bottle
okay and so yeah that's the problem that
with decoherence and with superposition
these people are talking about it see if
I can get this back up here where's it's
rese luge minorities so they talk about
superposition principle but what they're
saying is that they believe
they're dealing with particles with
discrete particles that's the first one
and you can see that in the rest of
what's underlined they're observed such
paths the paths of what of a particle
okay
and he talked about experimental
observation what do you mean observation
you did you observe the particle no they
did not observe the particle like
connemara they observed the effects of
something that was visible they observed
a concept they watched a movie of
something that they could not identify
they saw the curtain move and they
assumed that it was a spirit that's what
they're saying here and this spirit in
quantum mechanics is known as a particle
when it's convenient does it talk about
a particle and a wave when it's
convenient to talk about a wave and here
they're talking essentially about
photons about particles about
trajectories of particles because they
can't really talk about a trajectory of
a wave even though quantum says very
clearly and this is you'll see several
authors on this out there that light
travels as a wave and departs and
arrives at as a particle so they cannot
talk about the trajectories of particles
because quantum says that light can only
travel is a wave so what do they do they
say well yeah it's a wave packet we have
a wave that's traveling but the wave is
chopped off at the one end and at the
other and it's a little packet of a ball
of energy so they have the particle
mixed with the wave at all times they
need they need the wave because they
need to talk about wavelength and about
frequency and then they need the
particle for the impact and so in
between you know emission and arrival
what happens to that part of what is it
and they say well it's both it's a wave
and it's a packet it's a packet of
energy whatever that means to you it's a
vibrating whatever and unless they tell
us what is vibrating unless they tell us
what it are we tired by a little ball
are we talking about a little spring
what are we talking about and they never
will be able to tell you that because in
order to tell you that they have to
make an assumption they will never be
able to see it and they will never be
able to determine that indirectly all
they can do is do some armchair physics
sit back and say what could it possibly
look like that could be doing all these
things that's the only way to come up
with you know what physical object
mediates light the atom etc gravity and
magnetic magnetism okay so what are they
saying they say they have excitations of
surface plasmons what held is a plasma
so you look it up and it says in the
religion of quantum mechanics a plasma
is a quantity and amount of plasma
oscillation it's an amount of
oscillation just as light an optical
oscillation consists of photons the
plasma oscillation consists of plasmas
what is a plasma oscillation it's a
rapid oscillation of the electron
density we have oscillations of density
does any of that make any sense they
have oscillations of concepts this is
not semantics folks this is this is what
they're going to be telling you is a
particle there they're treating these
things as things these words as things
and they're not things a thing is that
which has shape you should be able to
draw it you should be able to illustrate
it for someone so someone looks at it
and says okay I see what what you're
talking about we can't have that in
quantum mechanics because they can't
tell you what they're talking about and
they confess you know here they say what
is a plasma plasma is an oscillation and
what is oscillating is the density so
you figure it out so none of these
reports that I was sent are scientific
they have nothing to do with science let
alone with physics that's the bottom
line on all these okay third third or
fourth I don't know where I'm at now but
not important was this Compton
scattering again we get mr. Compton we
resuscitated him and he talks about
single particle excitations
again he's already determined whoever
did this report they determined that
we're talking about particles and their
single lung the discrete particles and
these particles are being excited and so
they've already have this a priori
notion of what they're gonna be doing
they've never seen a particle but
they're already assuming that it's a
particle what did they get this where
did he get the idea that it is a
particle this is an assumption and their
assumption is wrong there is no such
thing as a particle out there and again
you can see that everywhere in the
reports as multiphone turn again you get
the word field out there what is a field
well if you look it up you'll find that
it's a vibration of an excitation or
vibration of a particle is a vibration
of the field that's that's what it is
so then they go with this you know
circular reasoning where you always end
up with concept you never end up with
with an object you never end up with a
stone in quantum mechanics again they
talk about observation they they observe
the fundamental linear x-ray matter
interaction they're observing
interactions you know so what did they
see I mean you can say you saw a tree
you can say you saw a dog you can't say
that you saw running and here they're
saying they saw interaction they saw
running they didn't see the dog okay
again they're talking about two
identical photons producing a single
photon and that's again this this notion
that they have that of superposition and
maybe if you run that it backwards
you'll get also the coherence where a
single photon somehow turns into two
photons momentarily virtual photons you
know they deal with all these
abstractions to try to give a physical
interpretation to what they're seeing in
the lab they never saw anything all
these are assumptions
they're irrational assumptions because
for a particle to be at two places at
once already has to tell you that you
got to reject your assumption and not
you know force your theory and again we
measure scattered photons with an energy
of blah blah blah ok so again they use
the word energy a word that has never
been defined richard fineman says we
don't know what energy is and of course
they'll never know they'll never even
bother to define these terms they don't
care they don't care about language
that's semantics as far as they are
concerned so they dismiss all these
things as you know petty arguments they
just want to do some lab work put an
equation and get a Nobel that's it
that's all they they call that science
ok so as you can see none of these
reports are scientific that's why
they're not even worth the even the time
I'm spending analyzing them but just so
that you know what's going on here and
talking about no here we talk about
knowledge the same report if you look it
up you'll find this on the Internet
ok let me make this bigger so I can read
this my age you you need to make things
a little bigger what did we do it says
and again they're talking about this
x-ray compton scattering and they said
the most fundamental interaction that's
what they investigated right
interactions between Ray's Ray's Ray's
is a concept there is no physical object
called array there's no physical object
called a beam beam and rays are figures
of speech what they're saying is that
they have a flow of photons and they're
going to call that flow that whole thing
that turn the row of apples they turn it
into a line that's what they're doing
here and they call that line array or
they call it a beam and so now they
forget about the fact that they're
dealing with discrete photons and they
say now we're going to talk about
interaction between rays and that
shorthand is unfortunate because all
that does is show that you know that
they have no idea of the physical
interpretation what do they observe they
observe the process great they observe
the concept so they didn't see the the
individual particles what they saw is a
process what did they see they said they
either they claim they say two photons
converted into single x-ray Photon
so we have two photons again convert
into a photon and I like that next line
says we know from experiments we know we
know means they already decided their
dogma they've got their religion down
pat you know they're not gonna accept
any other alternative because they
already know and here I have a comment
from Sabine Hassan Felder a lady who
apparently styles herself as a physicist
she's just a mathematical physicist and
in a report that she or a little article
she wrote what is the scientific
prediction she says we know we know we
know that our present theories are
correct to a high precision and new
theories cannot differ by much or they
are false already so in other words you
better fall in line with quantum and
general relativity because if you depart
too far away from from those two
established you know theories as they
call them then we know you that you're
already false that your theory that your
proposal is false we're not even going
to listen to you you're a crack you're a
crackpot but what is the issue the issue
is that precision has nothing to do with
science she's talking mathematics and a
theory is an explanation
so if quantum mechanics talks about
vibrating fields which are numbers
vibrating numbers and vibrating numbers
of particle and special and general
relativity talks about warping of
space-time a concept and that's what
they had Einstein says it's gravity then
we got a problem because it's got
nothing to do with precision it's got to
do with the irrational explanation these
people are offering for common phenomena
such as gravity or what they call for
like magnetism for all these other
you know phenomena that we see out there
so yeah that report is unscientific as
well and here we have here we have the
fourth one it's the electro positron
annihilation experiments okay from luck
LEP here you'll see review of final LEP
results okay and what they do in this
report this is just a simple report
saying putting up the date on you know
the measurements that they took with
with this machine okay and what are they
saying they're saying the most important
improvements being and they go into
vertex measurements they talk about
measurements so you measure a chair and
that's science you put your ruler to the
to the chair and said well the measures
two feet by two feet the seat does and
the legs are I don't know two feet also
two feet long so you measured the chair
it is that science is that what we'll
call science or you can do it with
weight you can say look how weight the
elephant is that science he measures you
know T tons great or you say look you
know I clocked the lion he runs at 30
miles per hour great is that science
just just taking measurements so keep
that in mind this is what these people
do and they put equations and they get a
Nobel and they say Oh see I'm I did
science and so they're talking about the
most important results from the LDP and
again it's all about measurements okay
but they do talk about you know positron
electron annihilation you know you get a
positron and you hit it it which is a
positive electron you can say and you
smash it against a negative electron and
you get empty space I guess annihilation
kind of says you get nothing so you get
two something's you get a black ball and
a white ball
and turns into a no-ball okay that's
that's what they're suggesting so they
were to get this nonsense called the
positron
well we got there from mr. Anderson Karl
Anderson he got a Nobel Prize for
discovering what I called a positron now
it's a positron not because it's a
suppository okay
it's a suppository because he supposed
he assumed that he was dealing with a
particle and here it is okay here's the
suppository Karl Henderson su positron
what is it he well what he did was in
1932 he took a picture in his chamber
and he found that there is this line
this curve and he comes from the bottom
going upwards okay and electrons go from
top to bottom and so he said well if
this one went from bottom to top then
this is a the opposite of an electron
it's a positive electron and so he came
up with the positron I'm not sure if he
was the guy who named it but the point
is since then it has been called the
positron positron is supposed to be a
positive electron if you can think of
that and so we have the positive
electron the negative electron and they
when you combine when they touch each
other they turn into nothing
okay and so he got a Nobel for this for
discovering this thing and one of the
problems with it well the suppose-a-tron
again is a super why is it well you see
the blow up there and you can see that
there are some little it's not a
continuous line like there are gaps
between it so the question is did the SU
positron jump like a jumping bean as
shown on the right
did it make a hole and then jump up and
then hit up make another hole and jump
up and make another hole is that how
this line was made and you can see that
I put a little drill bit next to it and
you say why the hell did Bill put a
drill
bit well because the pattern there looks
more like a drill bit see it never
occurred to Anderson or to any other
quantum people that that you know
they're not staring at particles that
they could be staring at something else
and here it is in the 19th century which
is what these people are doing still you
know the quantum mechanics the way they
do it is they do their holes like that
one they're like these this line when
they want to make a hole in the wall
they bring a cannon like like dr.
quantum did a minute ago you know when
he shoots these particles these balls
with his pop gun you know and this is
how they did in the 19th century see you
want to make a hole you bring your
cannon and you make holes in the wall by
throwing balls at it okay Wham that's
how they do it into nineteen section
this is the this is what Carl Anderson
thought was happening that a ball was
making holes in his wall okay was or
maybe a ditch if he came from the bottom
it was making this scratch right a ditch
a channel and it never occurred to these
people that there could be a different
mechanism and here's the different
mechanism there's the one suggested by
the rope model it's a drill bit we do
this in the 21st century we're a little
you know we don't bring a cannon to to
make a little hole in the wall we bring
a drill bit and make a turn with a drill
so quantum is still in the 19th century
making holes in the wall with cannons
and cannonballs and in science we do it
with drill bits it's a much more elegant
simpler mechanism to make holes in the
wall so compare you know Quantum's
cannonballs right to Bill's dobut so
there's different ways of making holes
in the wall different mechanisms and I'm
saying that electricity
because this this is the way they try to
explain electricity they think it's a
flow of electron beads and electricity I
say is a curling bit you have to have
all these atoms and they're connected to
each other physically connected to each
other forming a long string of atoms and
they curl like a snake
twirly in situ in place okay so I have a
different mechanism for what electricity
is and those holds that Tana Morra
thinks he made by throwing rocks at the
wall cannonballs bowling balls we do it
a little differently we do it with a
drill bit we go make a hole in a
different way and it's got to do a
little bit with uh that's what I'm
saying we should put the slit experiment
under vacuum let's get rid of all the
noise let's see if you can produce an
electricity in there with nothing in
there if you can produce a total vacuum
if you could breathe you know remove
every particle from your chamber
assuming 10 to the minus 100 or be
beautiful you know because that would
eliminate all the noise can you have a
current this is the important question
why because see these people think
they're shooting bullets and if you
evacuate the chamber of matter you've
increased the mean free path so now your
current should flow easier and that's
not the case it's exactly the opposite
the mormon matter you remove from the
system the less flow of electron beads
that you have in fact you want if you
remove all matter you won't have any
current whatsoever because and since
we're out of time i'm gonna continue
next we have to say the following
there's three mechanisms for what
electricity is - it won't belong to the
religion of quantum mechanics
and one of them is think of the wire in
a circuit and they say well how does
electron flow well first of all they
spiral they can't explain that they'll
never be able to explain that because
they don't they would not know why the
electron goes you know in a spiral
manner along the wire that's the first
one but then there's another problem and
that's that you know with a wire they
say okay you know the electron bead goes
from atom to atom it just goes to the
you know to the outer shell it just
continues from shell to shell but when
they're dealing with a slit experiment
or with a vacuum chamber when they're
dealing with a vacuum chamber they
forget about the atoms they get rid of
all the atoms and they just shoot
electron beads that's what they think
they're doing they think they're just
shooting electron be just a flow of
beads from the source to the wall
there's no atoms there they they're not
thinking of atoms because in the case of
the circuit they say well there's a wire
so let's assume it's iron so you have or
you have all these electron beads going
from iron to iron no problem they can
visualize that they say okay yeah
there's the atoms there from one atom to
the other knocking the other electron
and that one goes to the next row and
that one goes to the next one and knocks
that one out and so on down the line
like you know photoelectric effect you
have light hitting an electron moving at
how light manages to pinpoint the
electron is a different story because
the electron is so small and doesn't
have location turns out light always
finds and he kicks it out
they never figure that out you know they
don't care about these same qualitative
stuff okay but the question is when you
evacuate a chamber now you don't have
any atoms because that's what the
evacuation means that what vacuum means
that you removed all the atoms so now if
you have a cathode and an anode
be shooting electron beads just the bead
just a little tiny bead
bunch of them conceal yinz of them from
one electrode to the other the mean free
path has to be much greater now because
you removed all obstacles there's no
opposite you have perfect vacuum ten to
the minus 100 10 to the minus 1
millionth tour so now the beat should
flow easier if you shoot a billion beads
none of them should recombine with
anything because there's nothing there
all billion beads should go to you know
from one place to the other they should
all get DD anode in this case and that's
not the case the case is that the more
matter you remove from the chamber you
can't get an electric current flowing
which shows that electrons go from atom
to atom the correct one is the one with
a wire electron should go from atom to
atom you need atoms to for the electron
bead to flow and create current and in
the case of the rope model we don't have
electron flows
we don't have electron beads flowing
what we have is a drill bit twirling in
place all the atoms are connected
although really all the molecules
they're connected and they twirl
now you can explain magnetic field
because of the threads moving around you
can explain why the electron goes in a
spiral along the wire and you can
explain more importantly you can explain
voltage today they don't know what
voltage is they say there's a voltage
drop we'll call this one positive we'll
call that one negative they could have
set x and y they don't know what
positive negative means or North and
South they don't know what these things
mean they just these are labels under
the rope metal very easy clockwise
counterclockwise
that's something mother needs to
understand she understands clockwise and
counterclockwise because that's physics
you take a rope like in my case here
okay
and that's clockwise that's clockwise
okay I hope that's clockwise to you and
that's counterclockwise right no that's
clockwise sorry
that's clockwise and this is
counterclockwise okay so mother of
nature understands clockwise and
counterclockwise okay she doesn't
understand positive negative and I
explained voltage about a month ago but
I'll go over that again next time we're
a little bit out of time and I'll
continue with this discussion on
Wednesday so they tuned we're not done
with this yet again this guy opened up a
can of worms Pandora's box and we have
evil all over science now and I need to
address these issues okay
so I'll probably do a recap of what I
talked about today and then move on to
some of the other issues that were
brought up or that came up which are
misconceptions total misconceptions by
people like Peter who is as far as I
know a recent graduate a year ago or so
and all these people are coming out of
college with the wrong ideas and some of
those ideas are really all of them have
to do with this notion that there are
particles out there that they do
everything with particles that's the
mediator the invisible meteors are like
gravity everything particles okay so
we'll see you on Wednesday we'll see you
next Wednesday and I'll continue with
this discussion we'll see you that bye
bye